[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد اعلن رئيس شركه سبيس
اكس الون ماكس ايلون ماسك عفوا ان ما يقرب
من مئه جهاز استقبال الخدماتي الانترنت
المؤمن عبر شركه ستار لينك للاقمار
الصناعيه تعمل في ايران حاليا وذلك في
اطار جهد تدعمه واشنطن لتعزيز حريه
الانترنت والتدفق الحر للمعلومات
التغريده ماسك ردا على مقطع فيديو ونشره
على موقع التواصل مستخدم قال انه التقط
هذا الفيديو في شوارع ايران حيث توجد الان
حريه الاكبر وللنساء في اختيار ما كنا
يردنا تغطيه شعرهن ام لا وكان ماسك وعد في
سبتمبر اتاحه الانترنت عبر شبكه الاقمار
الصناعيه في ايران حيث تفرض السلطات قيودا
متزايده على الوصول الى الانترنت
[موسيقى]
معنى في الاستوديو صالح حميد الباحث في
الشؤون الايرانيه ومن القاهره اللواء محمد
الشهاوي الخبير العسكري والامنيه مرحبا
بكم
الكريمين استاذ صالح عبدالله
يستفيد المتظاهرون الايرانيون بشكل اساسي
من خدمه الانترنت
الايراني خاصه عندما يقوم همم مهاجمه
المتظاهرين في الشوارع
يعني راينا صور القتل المباشر يعني حتى
الاطفال اذا كان همم الانترنت
متوفرا همم
يساهم هذا الامر في همم يعني همم تصوير
وتوثيق هذه الجرائم ونشرها الى الراي
العام بالتاكيد هذه الاجهزه يعني لن تكون
متاحه للجميع لانها يعني همم مكلفه في
الدرجه الاولى حوالي 1200 دولار يعني
الجهاز ايضا صعوبه صعوبه من صعوبات
التقنيه انه لا يستطيع الايرانيون في كل
المناطق الحصول على همم الاجهزه التي
تستقبل الارسال لكن بامكان الناشطين همم
الاستفاده منها ونستطيع ان نقول انها نقل
نوعيه في النضال الايرانيين تستطيع كسر
حاجز التعتيم وهذا يعني انهم سيدخلون في
مرحله جديده لانه كان النظام يقتل
المتظاهرين بمعزل عن العالم الخارجي الان
الوضع مختلف همم سيحسب النظام الف حساب في
ظل العقوبات المتزايده والتغيير النسبي في
المواقف في الدوليه خاصه لهم المتحده همم
حتى اداره الرئيس الاوروبيين هذا سيساهم
في تسليط الضوء على انتهاكات من جهه
وزياده الضغط على النظام الجهه اخرى طيب
هذا من اجل ايصال كره المظاهرات همم
اللواء محمد شهاوي في القاهره هنا اسالك
همم 100 جهاز لخدمه الانترنت عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه عبر شبكه ستارلينج المؤمنه
التابعه لشركه بيس اكس تابعه انه الماسك
دخلت الى ايران همم ما مدى خطوره هذا ما
الذي يعنيه امنيا وعسكريا وكيف ترى اثره
كذلك على سير المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه في
ايران
اهلا بك يا استاذ صهيب
سيادتك الاستاذ صالح انا باقول فعلا انا
وصول هذه الاجهزه الى ايران تعتبر كارثه
كارثه على الجمهوريه الاسلاميه احنا بنعلم
ان هذه الاجهزه لا هدف هذا الهدف هو توفير
خدمه الانترنت الى همم داخل ايران هذه
الخدمه التي تم ايقافها بالاضافه الى
ايقاف مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ديت تعتبر اسلحه الدمار
العاجل يعني بمعنى ان ما يحدث في هذه
المنطقه يصل الى كل العالم وبالتالي هي
يعني بتنهي اا التعتيم على ما يحدث من
خلال هذه الاحتجاجات التي بدات منذ السادس
عشر من اين من ايلول سبتمبر الماضي اي منذ
اقرب من اكثر من 100 يوم وبالتالي
الاحتياجات مستمره ستجعل هذه اجهزه هو
توصيل ما يحدث من انتهاكات ضدها
اجهزه ستار هل فقط هي تستخدم من اجل
الوصول الى الانترنت يعني انه من اجل
ايصال ما يحدث الى العالم فقط ام اا لها
ربما استخدامات امنيه اخرى
لا هي اساسا يعني احنا نعلم ان خدمه
الانترنت بيكون هناك الانترنت الارضي
الانترنت الارضي عندما يتم الدوله نفسها
بيتم ايقافه او كما حدث في اوكرانيا ان
قامت القوات الروسيه بتدمير اهداف القيمه
المضاده وهي مواقع الاتصالات وشركات
الاتصالات يعني الكابلات
الاوبتكس ده كله ادى الى ان لا يوجد
انترنت ارضي داخل ال- داخل اوكرانيا فكان
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او من شركه
سبيس اكس اللي هي تحت قياده همم ماسك اللي
هو تم انشاء هذه الشركه في 2002 هو ادى
لاوكرانيا في الايام الاولى من العمليه
العسكريه 10,000 جهاز والان وصلت الى
25,000 في جهاز لتحقيق خدمه وتوصيل خدمه
الانترنت
ايران لن تفي لن تفي ولكن هي اساسا ستؤدي
الى ان هي يعني تصل صوت هؤلاء المتظاهرين
الى العالم الخارجي احنا نعلم ان هذه
الشركه التي يملكها له ماسك تمتلك 2000
قمر بتادور حول الارض على ارتفاع منخفض
علشان تقدر ان هي توصل خدمه الانترنت الى
كل من يقع اسفالها وبالتالي همم يعني سنجد
ان هذه الخدمه ستظهر ما يحدث من انتهاكات
داخل هذه الاحتجاجات لكن اعتقد ان هنا هذه
الاجهزه لابد ان تصل الى ايران وبتصل الى
ايران من خلال منطقتين منطقه كارمن شاى
ومنطقه الاهواز ومن خلال
معبر بانه الحدود من اقليم كردستان العراق
وبالتالي هناك صعوبه في ايصال هذه الاجهزه
نفسها وتعتبر محطات ارضيه بتتصل بالاقمار
الصناعيه لتوصيل الانترنت الى جمهور
المتظاهرين ولا ما بقول سابقه ان هذه
الاجهزه تعتبر من ضمن اسلحه الدمار العاجل
لانها بتصل بسرعه تصل صوت هؤلاء
المتظاهرين الى العالم اجمعنا نعلم ان
خلال هذه الحرب وان هناك حروب جديده تسمى
هذه الحروب الجديده اطلقت او سقط هذا
المصطلح الجديد الحروب الجديده هي ماري
كولدير همم في سنه همم ماري كالدور في
1999 عندما سقط مصطلح الحروب الجديده وهي
الحروب غير
المقيده وحروب المنطقه الرماديه التي
تستخدم فيها مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي جميل
طيب استاذ صالح حميد همم كما ذكر ضيفنا من
القاهره لواء انه دخول هذه الاجهزه
للانترنت عبر الاقمار الصناعيه هي كارثه
بالنسبه لنظام الايراني سؤال هناك السلطات
الايرانيه التي تمارس قمه عن شديدا على
هذه المظاهرات
ماذا تفعل تجاه هذا الخطر الدائم او اتجاه
هذه الكارثه كما وصفها ضيفنا من القاهره
بالطبع
النضال الكثير
الا ارصد ويراقب لكن حسب الخبراء رصد
ومتابعه هذه الاجهزه يعني صعب جدا لكن ما
اريد الاشاره اليه هو ليس فقط الناحيه
التقنيه ووصول المتظاهرين والمواطنين
والصحافيين الى الانترنت عن طريق هذه
الاقمار الصناعيه بل الرساله السياسيه من
وراء ذلك تطبيق النموذج الاوكراني في
ايران من خلال ايصال المساعدات
للشعب الايراني هذا هو له دلالات كثيره
يعني ربما لن يقتصر الدعم على هذا الدعم
التقني اذا استمرت الاحتجاجات ربما يتطور
لابعد من ذلك هذا يعني ان هناك المزيد من
الخطوات بعد ما تم تعيين همم لجنه لتقص
الحقائق من قبل مجلس حقوق الانسان في
الامم المتحده ثم طرد النظام الايراني من
لجنه المراه في المتحده الان هناك انترنت
همم الخزانه الامريكيه رفعت العقوبات
لتصديرها ولكن همم كان هناك حديث على انه
في الحرب الاوكرانيه كان هناك اضعاف
مضاعفه من من هذا الرقم الذي وصل لايران
همم من اجهزه ستار لينك هل همم لديكم
معلومات او هل تعتقدون ان هذا الدعم
سيستمر سيكون هناك المزيد من اجهزه ستار
تدخل ايران نعم حسب معلوماتنا الايرانيه
في الخارج وخاصه في الولايات المتحده
بداوا بجمع التبرعات همم كبيره همم
ارسال المزيد من الاجهزه بالماتور ربما
الالاف خلال الايام القادمه وهناك طرق
كثيره في الواقع ايران يعني بلد مترام
الاطراف الكثير من الموانئ هناك الحدود
همم البريه الجبال واعره همم تستطيع
السلطات السيطره عليها ادخالها امر سهل
جدا لكن انا اعود واركز على رسائل
السياسيه همم من وراء ذلك لانه المتظاهرين
استمروا حتى في ظل قاطع الانترنت هناك
حاله ثوريه همم في البلد همم يعني تغيير
هذه المواقف الدوليه هي احد اهم العوامل
الاساسيه لاستمرار المظاهرات لانه في كان
النظام يقتل
ويعني شعبي راى انه الدول الاوروبيه
والاداره الامريكيه تذهب للتفاوض مع
النظام وتغض النظر عن كل هذه الانتهاكات
الان تبدل هذه المواقف ولو كانت نسبيه ولو
انها لم ترقى الى مستوى الطموح لكنها مهمه
جدا
وسهمت في زخم اكبر لهذه الاحتجاجات
المستمر طيب سيره لواء في القاهره كما اا
ذكرت همم يعني دخول اجهزه ستار لينك يمكن
ادراجه كما وصفته وحضرتك ضمن الحروب
الجديده همم يعني الاجهزه صغيره نسبيه
وكما ذكر ضيفه هنا في الاستديو انه من
السهل جدا ادخالها وبالتالي توفير
الانترنت المقطوعه عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
في المقابل هل النظام الايراني برايك هو
جاهز لمجابه هذه الحرب الجديده
هو انا عايز اقول فعلا ان هناك صعوبه في
ايصال هذه الاجهزه الى داخل الايراني هناك
حدود محكومه لكن في اوكرانيا احنا نعلم ان
هناك دعم غربي وصل الى اكثر من 100 مليار
دولار من الاسلحه والمعدات فكان في هناك
سهوله من دخول اجهزه ستارلينج هو وسط الى
25 الف جهاز او محطه ارضيه تتصل بالاقمار
الصناعيه الى اوكرانيا لكن بالنسبه
للايران هي بتصل من خلال التهريب ان يعني
بصعوبه جدا انها تصل بالاضافه الى يعني
همم ارتفاع ثمنها اللي تصل زي ما قال
استاذ صالح كده من يعني 1500 الى 2000
دولار لكن انا عايز اقول كيف سترد واشنطن
على تحدي ايلين ماسك بحاجه بتخطي حجب
الانترنت ازاي ان هذه الاجهزه هي علشان
يعني تقوم
بالتخطي ان ما يبقاش في انترنت لا هم
عاوزين يبقى في انترنت
ان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه او ايران انها
تقوم بالتشويش على ترددات هذه الاجهزه ال-
اا المحور الثاني الذي ممكن ان تقوم به
ايران هو انها تخفف القيود على حجم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي حتى لا يتم توجيه
مستخدم الانترنت الى اجهزه الستار لينك
وبالتالي احنا شايفين 100 يوم حتى الان من
بدايه هذه الاحتجاجات هي بدات في التناقص
الان غير الايام الماضيه هي دي الخارجيه
الايرانيه اتهمت واشنطن بانها بتكون بتدخل
في الشؤون الداخليه في الداخل الايراني من
خلال تخفيف العقوبات على ايه هي المفروض
هناك عقوبات على ايران لكن واشنطن خففت
العقوبات على قطاع الاتصالات حتى يسهل
تسهيل الانترنت ووصوله الى داخل الايراني
فهي يعني همم بتقول ان ذلك تدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه لكن اعتقد ان يعني تهريب هذه
الاجهزه بيلقى صعوبه كبيره جدا اللي هي
الداخل وعلشان كده احنا بنسمع النهارده من
يوم 16 سبتمبر حتى الان عندما قال ايلون
ماسك بيقول 100 جهاد واحنا نعلم في الجهه
المقابل في اوكرانيا يوجد
25,000 جهاز وبالتالي اعتقد بالرغم انه
كارثه لكن لن يقوم بالتاثير الكبير على
الداخل الايراني لهيام الدوله الان بالعمل
على تقفيف القيود على الشبكه الداخليه
للانترنت في ايران وتخفيف القيود على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي نعم شكرا جزيلا
لكم
الكريمين من القاهره لواء محمد شهاوي
الخبير العسكري والامني والاستاذ صالح
حميد الباحث عشان الايراني»